we're on problem 43
43 which statement describes the graph
of the following equation they write
x squared
plus y squared
plus 4 x
minus 6 y
minus 3 is equal to 0.
and essentially you want to get this
into kind of standard conic square
format i don't know what's officially
called and and you do that by completing
the square on both the x and the y
i guess you can call it subpolynomial
and then you should be able to recognize
what kind of conic section it is so
let's separate out the x and the y terms
so the x terms i'll do that in blue
you get x squared
plus
x
right and then we're going to add
something that makes it a perfect square
and you can already guess what we're
going to add let's say we're going to
add 4 right because x squared plus 4x
plus 4 is x plus 2 squared so i'm going
to write that in magenta just so we
remember that we added it this came out
of nowhere right now so if i added plus
4 here i'm going to have to add plus 4
on this side right
plus 4. this is the equal sign
all right
and then let me do the y terms i'll do
it in this brown color plus
y squared
minus 6 y
and then what would i add here half of
minus 6 is minus 3 and then if i were to
square that
minus 3 squared i'll do it in this
magenta color again is plus 9
right plus 9. so i want to add plus 9 to
the right hand side as well
right and then finally i have a and of
course this is y minus 3 squared this
whole thing right here
and then i have that minus 3
right over here
all right now let me rewrite this term
right here
i added this plus 4 here for a reason so
that i could make this into
x plus two
squared
and then plus and i added this plus nine
here for a reason so i could make this
y
minus three squared
and then let's say well let me just keep
the minus three there for now minus let
me do it in the other column minus three
is equal to four plus nine four plus
nine is what is equal to thirteen
let's add the three to both sides of
that equation so you get
x plus 2
squared plus
y minus 3 squared is equal to
16.
and now if you think about it this is
the form
of a circle right this is
you know i
x minus
a
squared plus y minus b squared is equal
to r squared where the center of the
circle is at where
so whatever the x value is what makes
this equal to zero
so it's x
it's minus two
and then the y value of its center is
what makes this equal to zero minus two
comma three that's its center and its
radius is the square root of sixteen so
the radius is equal to four it can't be
negative four because you can have a
negative radius so the answer is a
circle with radius at minus two comma
three
minus two comma three and radius 4 and
that's choice d
problem 44
what is the solution to the equation
5 to the x
is equal to
17.
okay so that means that if we take if we
take the log base so 5 to the x power is
equal to 17 we could rewrite this in log
format that means that
log
base 5
of 17
is equal to
x
and you could you could you could read
this exactly the same way you read that
5 to the x is equal to 17. of course
that's not one of our choices and this
is fairly useless on your calculator
because you don't have a log base 5
button
and so you just have to let me write it
this way x is equal to
i'm just switching it log base 5 of 17
just because it's easier for me to
to to deal with
and so and this is just i prove it in in
previous khan academy logarithm videos
but there's just a general property and
i'll write the property here if x
is equal to log
base
i don't know
base b
of
a
that that is equal to
log
base 10
of a
divided of a lower case a divided by log
base 10
of b and you just have to pick the same
base both you could have the base you
could have the natural log of a divided
by the natural log of b you could do
whatever log you want but log base 10 is
on your calculator so that's why this is
convenient so we could say that log this
is equal to the log
base 10
of 17 divided by the log
of 5. and that should be a choice yep
that's choice d
next question
they say if log
this is problem 45
let me write it down 45
45. they say if log
base 10
of x is equal to minus 2 what is the
value of x
so that essentially is not 10 to the
minus 2 power is equal to x
to the minus 2 power
is equal to
x
right all a logarithm is it tells you
what number do i have to what exponent
do i have to raise the base to to get
whatever i'm inputting into the
logarithm function right
so if i raise 10 to the minus 2 i get x
10 to the minus 2 that's 1 over 10
squared is equal to x which is 1 over
100 is equal to x and that's choice c
choice c
i think i could do problem 46 right here
which equation is equivalent to
log
base three
of one ninth
is equal to
is equal to x
okay well
just
read it the exact same way we read
question 45. this is just saying that 3
to the x power is equal to 1 9. so let's
write that 3 to the x power is equal to
1 9.
is that one of the choices well yeah
let's choice c
three that's all
that was suspiciously easy i think
you think i have to know the definition
of what a logarithm is
okay problem 47 i'll clear this screen
let me switch colors
which is oh this i'll cut cut and paste
this one because this is interesting let
me blow it up a little bit
so you can definitely read it
because they want us to identify an
incorrect step
okay let me go here
okay they ask us
which is the first incorrect step in
simplifying log base 4 of 4 over 64. all
right step one they said log base 4 4
over 64 is equal to log base 4 4
minus log base 4 64. that's right
whatever your when you divide within the
logarithm function or you know what
you're inputting into the logarithm
function that's equivalent of
of taking the the log of the top one and
subtracting from that the log of the
bottom and that's all a function of
actually when you divide two numbers of
the same base you subtract their
exponents and we prove that we prove
that in previous videos but that's just
good enough that you know that's the
correct that's the correct step right
now
so what's log base 4 of 4 4 to what
power is equal to 4 well that yeah sure
that's equal to 1.
right 4 to what power is equal to 64.
let's see 4 squared is 16 right 4 to the
1 is equal to 4
4 squared is equal to 16.
4 to the third is 4 times 16 which is
64.
so 4 to the 4 4 to the third power is
64. so this is 3.
so this should be
this should be let's see
log of 4
minus 60 right this should be a 3 here
this should be a minus 3.
so this step 2 was the first incorrect
step they mis-evaluated log base 4 of
64. they thought it was 16 for some
reason i guess they divided 64 by 4 but
it's actually 4 to the 3rd power of the
16. so sorry 4 to the third power is 64.
so the answer there is 3. so step 2 is
the first incorrect step
next question
all right
all right let me see
clear image
invert colors
alright let me copy and paste this one
too because this is interesting
i'll try to copy and paste as many of
the word problems as possible
this is problem 48 let me write that
down in the corner
right in that corner jeremy michael
shannon and brenda each work the same
math problem at the chalkboard each
student's work is shown below their
teachers said that while two of them had
the correct answer only one of them had
arrived at the correct conclusion using
correct steps
okay they want to know which is a
completely correct solution okay let me
just copy and paste those
so completely correct solution
okay so let's just think about what
everyone did here
looks like this is dealing with
exponents
all right he had x to the third times x
to the minus seven okay this is already
wrong right because x to the minus seven
is one over x to the seventh this is one
over x to the seventh so this should be
a plus right here
so he's wrong
okay shannon x to the third times x to
the minus seven yep that equals x to the
third over x to the positive seven
and then let's see
one over x to the four
that is right right because this is
equal to x to the three minus seven so
that's x
to the minus four
so x to the minus four
is one over x to the four so as far as i
can tell shannon's work looks pretty
good
oh this was a little weird how she went
straight to one over x to the four maybe
just kind of skipped a step michael's
work x to the third over x to the minus
7. okay he made the same mistake as
jeremy x to the minus 7 when you put in
the denominator becomes x to the
positive 7.
not right
and then let's see brenda's work got
this step right
but then this should be x to the minus 4
x to the minus 4 power so this is not
this is not correct
so the only person who got it right was
shannon and what choice is that shannon
is choice c
choice c
out of time see you in the next video